you
so welcome everybody good afternoon
thank you you're such a quiet serious
audience must be because we're in the
law school right so this is a very
special occasion and I thank all of you
for joining us
this is Yale's celebration of the 60th
anniversary of the Marshall scholarships
and the scholarships as you know we're
named in honor of George C Marshalls
plan to rebuild Europe's economy and
restore stability following the Second
World War they were designed as a
reflection of the spirit of the Marshall
Plan that is the scholarships were to
provide opportunities for further
international understanding and dialogue
by bringing outstanding u.s. scholars to
the UK to pursue Advanced Study in the
program's first 60 years more than 1800
Marshall scholarships have been awarded
118 of them to jelly's and six in the
most recent cohort so welcome everyone
students faculty and staff who are here
as Marshall scholars and also to our
distinguished visitors from the
fellowship program as you know today we
are joined by a very special visitor
rabbi Lord Jonathan Sacks
and I will tell you a little more about
his background in a moment
but first I want to speak to the special
connections among the occasion we are
celebrating the visitors who have joined
us today and yell so the presence of
religious dialogue at universities at
this university is as old as
universities themselves yell as you
probably know was established more than
three centuries ago by colonial
clergyman Ezra Stiles president of Yale
in the late 18th century was a
Congregationalist minister who traveled
to Rhode Island in 1763 to be present at
the founding of this country's first
synagogue
so yells very core is a history of the
kind of understanding and dialogue
championed by the Marshall scholars and
a conversation between a yale president
and the leader of a faith community is
perhaps not as unusual as one might
think one of the Marshall scholars who
is here in the room today is on stage
with me now where he will be in a moment
and that's Andrew Claver he is a
remarkable example of the qualities that
these scholarships celebrate and promote
he graduated summa [ __ ] laude from Yale
College in 2004 where he was Phi Beta
Kappa president and one too many awards
and other honors for me to name them
here a couple of them though he received
the David Everett entler award at
graduation for best exemplifying the
qualities of courage strength of
character and high moral purpose and the
Hadley Prize as valedictorian of his
class Andrew was a 2004 Marshall scholar
he went to Oxford earning Master of
Science degrees in financial economics
and economic history and he also holds a
JD MBA from Harvard among his many many
distinctions and received the
president's environmental Youth Award at
the White House for his commitment to
improving the environment served with
the United Nations interagency task
force on orphaned and vulnerable
children and presented even ground the
nonprofit organization he founded to
support South African and Ugandan
children Orford orphaned by or
vulnerable due to hiv/aids
he presented it at the World Economic
Forum in Davos Switzerland a tireless
public servant he is the co-author of
the book social entrepreneurship in the
age of atrocities changing our world he
is now an investment professional at
Paulson & Company in New York and
president-elect of the Association of
Marshall scholars it was Andrews idea to
bring rabbi sacks to yell and I thank
him for that excellent idea
and I'd like you all to join me in
welcoming Andrew who will speak just for
a moment about the Marshall scholarships
a closed Accord between our two
countries
is essential for the good of mankind in
this turbulent world so wrote George
Marshall in a letter to the first class
of Marshall scholars 60 years ago George
Marshall was a soldier a statesman and a
humanitarian as a soldier he served as
the Secretary of Defense and the u.s.
army chief of staff organizing the
largest military expansion in US history
during World War two as the Statesman he
served as Secretary of State and as a
humanitarian he served as president of
the American Red Cross for all of this
and his eponymous plan George Marshall
received the Nobel Peace Prize the only
career officer in the United States
military to garner this honor a word
about the Marshall Plan a word about the
Marshall scholarship and then on to our
main event consider the Marshall plans
scope and scale a 13 billion dollar
undertaking when it was announced in
1947 that is equivalent to a hundred and
sixty billion dollars today for
perspective our entire foreign aid
budget last year fifty two billion
dollars the Marshall Plan was three
times that amount as you thank you to
America for the Marshall Plan
the British created the Marshall
scholarship six decades ago as an
enduring expression of gratitude and an
enduring expression of faith in our US
UK special relationship Marshall
scholars include
Nobel prize-winning scientists Pulitzer
prize-winning authors professors and
university presidents including the most
recent past Dean of this distinguished
law school Harold Koh a Supreme Court
justice musicians and visual artists
astronauts start-up hedge fund banking
in private equity Titans
nonprofit trailblazers physicians
soldiers cadets Marines public servants
and as I recently learned from our
quarterly newsletter a discoverer of
dinosaurs marshals who are currently on
the scholarship in the UK often have the
opportunity to meet with members of
parliament cabinet secretaries the prime
minister at 10 Downing Street and where
honorary patron His Royal Highness
Prince Charles not even George Marshall
got to meet Prince Charles and so in
conclusion this afternoon were in for a
very special treat just as George
Marshall and his martial plan played an
invaluable role in strengthening the
cherish bonds between the United States
and the United Kingdom so too has lured
rabbi sacks strengthened the bonds of
Understanding between faith communities
at home and abroad and so too has
president Solvay strengthened the bonds
of Understanding between Yale and New
Haven and Yale and the rest of the world
who are in Batumi m-- light and truth is
mother Yale's motto I have no doubt that
today's discussion will yield ample
amounts of both please join me in
welcoming President Salva and Lord Rabbi
Jonathan Sacks
Thank You Andrew and thank you once
again for suggesting the idea of today's
program once again thank you all for
coming this is a wonderful assemblage of
the Yale community and the Greater New
Haven community and I'm delighted to see
so many of you with us this afternoon it
is now my great honor and pleasure to
introduce our guest of honor
rabbi Lord Jonathan Sacks rabbi sacks is
widely recognized as one of the world's
foremost religious leaders and as a
philosopher and author and a moral voice
of our times
he is the ingerborg and Ira Rennert
global distinguished professor of Judaic
thought at New York University the Kris
Allen efrat family University professor
of Jewish thought at Yeshiva University
and a professor of law ethics and the
Bible at King's College London from 1991
to 2013 he served as chief rabbi of the
United Hebrew congregations of the
Commonwealth only the sixth incumbent
since that role was formalized in 1845
he was knighted by Queen Elizabeth the
second in 2005 and made a life peer
taking his seat in the House of Lords in
October 2009 through his philosophical
contributions to Judaism and to society
more widely he is in the words of His
Royal Highness the Prince of Wales a
light unto this nation and I might add
to this world
rabbi Sachs has published extensive
writings I know so many of you are
familiar with them including a widely
read series of commentaries on the Torah
and works on heritage tradition faith
and religion and science a book to be
released in the United States this fall
we'll examine the phenomena of religious
violence and extremism today I'll be
talking with him more about faith about
the shifting global landscape about
education and about current affairs and
if we have a little time at the end I
have some questions that some of you
submitted on cards
we will try to get to them as well so
please join me in welcoming rabbi sacks
okay let me just get set up here and
we'll get started there we go so Shalom
Aleichem you know Yale University and
institutions of higher learning like it
are no longer religious institutions per
se and yet there seems to be a role that
universities can play in promoting
interfaith dialogue and promoting
understanding and in promoting
scholarship on religion itself and I'm
curious how you view that role for a
modern contemporary research university
like Yale well mr. president if I made
first of all I want to say thank you on
behalf of Elena myself with this
wonderful invitation it is the first
time we've had the privilege of visiting
Yale and I regard this is a day we will
never forget to set foot in these holy
acres v United States presidents for
them since the seventies nineteen
Supreme Court justices fifty-two Nobel
laureates
in the immortal words of that classic of
American literature the lego movie
awesome and may I say mr. president even
more or strive to be in your presence I
mean to be number one 23rd president
number two the sign of surely the most
distinguished rabbinic dynasty of recent
times number three a pretty cool banjo
player of bluegrass music you don't just
teach multiple intelligences you are
multiple intelligences so this is a huge
privilege I think you know in this
context of a university set up by
Congregationalists as a religious
institution should remind us of a truth
that we're in danger of forgetting that
it was religion the judeo-christian
tradition the Abrahamic tradition if you
like that understood the pursuit of
knowledge as something that God wants
from us and if I may because this is
really you know we're we're just coming
up to festival Passover and I I think to
myself you know if you read the biblical
narrative Exodus 12 and 13 absolutely
fascinating narrative here you are
you've got the opportunity to make a
speech that will go out down in history
as one of the great speeches of all time
your people have been in exile for 210
years there have been enslaved they've
been subject to slow genocide and you
after a series of miracles you as Moses
you're just about to lead your people to
freedom you gather them together what do
you talk about you might talk about
Liberty you might talk about the
destination but lay ahead the land
flowing with milk and honey or if you
were made of sterner stuff you might
talk about the difficulties you will
encounter on the way what Nelson Mandela
called the long walk to freedom any one
of those things would have been a great
speech of a great leader Moses did none
of those things which made him a unique
leader three times in those two chapters
he comes back again and again and again
to the same subject when your child asks
you in the future
this answer him that when your children
say this answer them that you shall
teach your child in that day they want
freedom and he is talking about
education he's talking about the distant
future why because to defend a country
you need an army but to defend a
civilization you need education and that
is why Yale and places like it are the
very foundation of a free society that
was not the original vision of Yale's
founders which was a specific faith but
now Yale has widened it to accept to to
Lois's like us for the people from the
other side like us to sit together and
join you in this collaborative pursuit
of truth and so really has earned the
basic concept of the university then the
universe of discourse well we put aside
our prejudices where we listen
respectfully to those whose views are
different from ours and where we
realized that by arguing together we may
be able to avoid fighting it together
and that I salute Yale for and all it is
shown from the day was founded but above
all today so first of all thank you once
again for being here and you're very
nice to recognize my family I don't
think the Sullivan Czech heritage has
fully appreciated bluegrass music yet
and you're bringing the regular give
them a bit more emotional intelligence
they get it don't get it anyway the the
it's interesting you know 60 years ago
you're right when the Marshall
scholarship program was founded it would
have been unthinkable for the two of us
to be sitting here in front of an
audience at Yale University having this
conversation maybe less unthinkable that
a visiting rabbi would have a dialogue
with a university president but they're
probably other more unthinkable parts of
this so as I think about that and I
think about how universities have
changed in the sixty years of the
Marshall scholarship program what about
the future
what's our what is our highest part
as a university pursuing the truth in
the next decades I had what you know
just listening to Andrew talking about
the Marshall scholars I think it's very
important you know for me as as as an
Englishman to pay tribute to George
Marshall I mean here was a man who is
not only great in winning a war but
great is still in winning a piece it
takes courage to win a war but it takes
wisdom and generosity of heart to win a
piece and I would have thought that is
what has to be born here on campuses
like this here is the place where people
of all cultures and ethnicities you know
I think this is true about universities
throughout the world
I remember going up to the University of
a Dean just a year or two ago think
that's right in the north of Scotland
you know the only thing that really
knows about Aberdeen's are herrings you
know it's the center of the herring
industry and III you know therefore
those sort of degree awarding ceremony
and I see that almost every country
under the Sun large East European
contingent a lot of Chinese students I
believe north of Scotland I think they
heard about the malt whiskey they didn't
hear about the weather and and I think
the university becomes as it were the
matrix of that mindset that we will need
if we are to successfully negotiate the
21st century to respect and one at the
same time both our commonalities and our
differences we collaborate in pursuit of
the truth but each of us comes to that
sacred arena from a different starting
point and it's those differences brought
to this common good of the pursuit of
truth of wisdom and understanding that
is the world so badly needs now
dey's we're going through one of those
periods when the pilot says you know
fasten your safety belts we're going
through a period of turbulence and I
don't know if you saw their little
editorial David Brooks did just a day or
two ago talking about what happens to
leadership in troubled times it gets
more primal it gets more defensive
aggressive again it begins to generate
and deepen tensions and that's why you
need a counter force and that counter
force is the role of the university a
great Scottish philosopher alasdair
macintyre once said don't ask of an
institution what does it do ask of it of
what conversations is it the arena and
the university is the place where people
of all cultures and creeds can come
together as voices in that conversation
so let's imagine for a minute stepping
out of the University and into the
public square one of the conversations
we've been having here is about the role
of faith and faith communities in the
public square Tony Blair was here and
talked to us taught our students about
in a way his own personal faith journey
and how it informed his work in Northern
Ireland and I'd be interested in your
own thoughts about the proper role of
faith in the public square both as a
motivator of individuals and as a
potential way of reconciling conflict
you must understand this president the
British and American cultures are polar
opposites in this respect where Tony
Blair was Prime Minister
every woman knew is a very religious man
but whenever anyone asked him about
religion on his press officer Alastair
Campbell intervened and said we don't do
God so he was actually forbidden to
utter that word during the whole of his
prime ministership in America every
presidential inaugural address since
Washington's first with the sole
exception
second from 1789 to 2013 has mentioned
God which created a very interesting
situation because President Barack Obama
came to Britain a couple of years ago
and addressed both houses of parliament
and I was standing next to a bishop and
I said let's see how negotiate he
negotiates this because it's as American
president he's got to mention God and in
the English Parliament he can't so so we
listened that he invoked the creator
saying managed to sync signal deference
without mentioning the G word but the
truth is the role of religion in the
public square really met the last word
the first and last greatest word on this
was really said by alexis de tocqueville
back in 1832 the wisest observer of this
of all time who coming from France
understanding that religion had power
but very little influence coming to a
country where First Amendment separation
of church and state where religion had
no power at all he expected to find it
had no influence and found exactly the
opposite that it had an enormous amount
of influence he called it the first of
America's political institutions or as
we would say nowadays the first of its
pre political institutions what he
realized was that religion did not get
involved in Party politics he asked
ministers why and they said because
politics is divisive and if we got
involved in it we would become divisive
too and so they kept their role of
supporting individuals families
communities charities what he called the
art of association which he called the
apprenticeship of Liberty and in general
maintaining the moral landscape the
moral garden if you like and that is the
role of religion today it is in civil
society as opposed to party political do
course and it's rose absolutely vital
because look at America or look at
England you know marriages marriages
it's disappearing 48% of children in
England are born outside of marriage
fewer people are marrying they're
marrying later 40% of marriages ending
in divorce I mean this is horrendous as
for communities you know a British
medical charity did research exercise
two years ago and found the average 18
to 30 euro 30 year old British citizen
has 237 Facebook friends when asked on
how many of those could you rely the
average answer was two so we're losing
math families were losing communities
we're becoming the lonely crowd and we
need religion in the public domain as a
unifying force by staying away from
party politics but as a moral force I
once called the religion the redemption
of our solitude and we need it right now
you know your comments remind me of a
study done by my undergraduate advisor
at Stanford University he's now passed
away his name is david rosenhan and he
was very interested in the role of
religion in students lives and the way
they thought about their religious
commitments you know when they entered
larger society after graduation and
among the the the among his findings
through surveys that he conducted was
that 95 percent of college students this
was at Stanford actually so California
college students said endorse the
statement you know that I believe in God
95 percent say yes and then he asked do
you believe that this God is essentially
involved in your daily life and his way
of the decisions you make and your
everyday behavior you know throughout
your life and something like I don't
remember the exact number but something
like 2/3 of the student says yes I
believe in a God who is aware of me as
an individual what I'm thinking and what
I'm feeling my guess is if david
rosenhan had also asked them and when
you leave the university and you enter
the public square whether it's the
business world or professional world or
public service or leadership will your
faith guide you in decision they would
have rejected that no no no no that's
private that's my own why the disconnect
why why the discontinuity between
people's beliefs and their sense of the
role that faith can play I you know it
seems to me that neither the founders of
Yale nor nor us today can possibly
accept that I mean we you grew up with
the prophets of ancient Israel Amos
hazard Isaiah Jeremiah these were social
critics the world's first social critics
they would have said a great deal
frankly about what happens you know what
is there any nation state today that can
actually control a multinational
corporation for instance and we work
this out if they don't like the tax
regime here they'll go and base
themselves there if they don't like the
labor laws here they'll go move to
another country you are creating ISM
value free zone international capitalism
now I mean Adam Smith who wrote The
Wealth of Nations also wrote a book
called Theory of Moral Sentiments he did
not believe you can run an economy
without those moral values and of course
we know from from the most famous little
bit of of mathematical in the innovation
of the 20th century
John Vaughn ointments invention of game
theory and the iterated prisoner's
dilemma which tells you that two
individuals pursuing their own interest
will not maximize the good for either of
them individually or collectively unless
they trust one another in other words
all we Adam Smith Wealth of Nations
market economics in the world will not
get you the ultimate outcome that Adam
Smith thought it would do without the
presence of trust in fact Adam Smith
himself even gave it a quasi-religious
description he spoke of the invisible
hand so and if that is not divine
providence I don't know what is but it
was near to saying it is you could in
Edinburgh with David Hume the atheist
within hearing distance but you know it
was pretty good nonetheless so the idea
that you can leave God at home and not
when you go out into the market or into
the professions or internet into other
those those demands for honesty
integrity transparency accountability
those things that the prophets insisted
on we need even more today so I never
believed you could leave God at home
besides which even if you tried to he
was there ahead of you in the
marketplace given what is happening in
the wider world and the topic of your
new book I'm wondering if you'd be
willing to entertain some questions
about current affairs and maybe we
should start with recent events in
Europe the Charlie Hebdo attacks the
kosher supermarket attacks everybody is
deeply troubled by these kinds of
attacks by by often young men with ties
to extremist Islamic groups who use
violence you know what how are we to
understand religious extremism among
Muslim communities in in Europe what do
we think is driving
what do we think accounts for it and is
is it any different in the UK and on the
continent it's a you know it's a it's a
really tough one which is why I wrote
the book because you know if you can't
get it in a soundbite you know you you
have to spend the ninety thousand words
to explain it but let me in the context
of today's conversation tell you what I
think has happened I think that was a
huge move in Europe in the 17th century
beginning in the 17th century after a
century of Wars of Religion and we're
back there today I mean we're really
back in the 17th century and the great
Wars of Religion what happened then of
course is a series of individuals sat
down and said other things on which we
of different faiths whether we're
Catholic or Protestant we can agree on
and out of that came not only the
philosophy of Descartes and the science
of Newton but the political theory of
Hobbes and Locke and and Spinoza and the
birth of the modern and there was a
feeling somehow that if you said goodbye
to religious identity which had been the
cause of a century of war then you can
move into a universal order of reason
and observation whose twin deities would
be science and philosophy it was a
beautiful dream the 18th century dream a
dream of reason but the trouble is that
you know was a philosophy professor in
Colombia called Sidney Morgan but it was
trying to explain to his students how
Plato's theory of forms didn't quite
work out so he took them to a Jewish
restaurant and he ordered soup and the
waiter said why do you want chicken soup
borscht
vegetable soup and Morgan birthday said
no I don't want any of those I just want
soup not having it taken of course in
philosophy the way to gave up in despair
but you know you cannot have identity in
general you have to have it in
particular so because I think anyway you
eat soup and that's the only way you
speak in language there is not a meta
language there are the six hundred
thousand six thousand languages spoken
today plus the six thousand them first
which is Google Translate have you
noticed how Google translates everything
into a language somewhat resembling
English devoid of any kind of
comprehensibility anyway the so you know
people in the 19th century rebelled
against the age of reason and the 19th
century was the age of nationalism it
was the age of returning identities and
that in the 20th century led to two
world wars so the West is embarked on
actually an almost unprecedented
experiment on a world without identities
in which all that matters is the self
and any larger affiliation is something
we don't talk about now a world without
identities this hugely individualistic
world in which moral relativism is the
Creed post-modernism is the philosophy
whose icon is the selfie we are the age
of the selfie and and and you cannot
have a world without entities you can't
take refuge in the universal and you
can't take refuge in the individual the
tribes will somehow return and that is
what's happening among Muslim youth they
come from a tradition that venerates
tradition which has a very strong
religious identity and they cannot take
a world in which they're no identities
you know in which religious commitments
or loyalties just a laughter
and Riddick religion in Europe is
ridiculed they can't take you and I
actually think there's nowhere else for
them to escape - were you with me
because nationalism and national
identities have disappeared no European
country today has a national identity
you know they don't you ask an
Englishman what makes England and
English they don't know that I'm got a
clue
we've abolished national identity
America hasn't it still has a narrative
that narrative is still rehearse by
every president of America every four
years on January the 10th or 20th
wherever it is in his inaugural address
America has a narrative England has no
narrative when I taught start talking to
prep politicians about national
narratives they don't even know what
you're talking about so you know trying
to have a world without identity forces
people to escape into identities and
when those identities are adversarial
when they're built on hostility to the
modern world then you get religious
extremism and you get violence and we
have some very very dangerous so when
when Marta and I have difficulty
sleeping we often turn the radio on and
listen to BBC World at night not because
it helps us sleep but because it's very
kind of the best radio news that you can
listen to in this country it's the best
you can sleep to it and I believe this
is where this came from there was a BBC
poll that showed that one out of four
British Muslims felt some sympathy for
the Charlie Hebdo attackers and I
wondered whether we should be concerned
that one out of four British Muslims
felt this way or actually relieved that
three out of four British Muslims do not
feel that way how do you understand I
will tell you very candidly
that the people almost
concerned are the Muslim parents whose
children are being radicalized because
what is happening of course and this is
why it's happening now what what created
the Wars of Religion in the 16th and
17th centuries was a revolution in
information technology it was called
printing the end result is that all the
ideas really put forward by Martin
Luther and his ninety-five theses on the
door of Wittenberg Cathedral had already
been said at Oxford one of my alma
Marxist I'm sorry to bring up such
things but but but but they'd been said
by John Wycliffe in Oxford two centuries
earlier but Wickliffe was before
printing and luther was after printing
and the second you have a revolution in
information technology you can subvert
all existing structures of authority
because you can reach people directly
through the book they don't have to
listen to to the priest delivering the
sermon and that is what is happening now
I mean Islam Islamist radicalism was
really born in 1928 by the creation and
by hasan bana of the muslim brotherhood
but it is suddenly exploded into life
now because of the internet and the
interval not merely demolishes the
authority of the of the mosque it
demolishes the authority of parents
these are parents whose kids are being
radicalized by the internet and they
don't know how to control them so we are
in a very very difficult situation and
it's pretty scary for everyone in Europe
right now including as I say
three-quarters of the Muslim community
scary to them as well yeah let me ask
you a little bit follow that up with a
little bit of a question on how we
should talk about it you know there's
been in this country anyway a sense that
one that radical Islam is a misnomer
maybe or at least difficult to talk
about president
Obama has been criticized that for
saying that you know the Islamic State
of Iraq and Syria Isis ISIL is not about
Islam at all it's not Islamic the
premier prime minister of France has
said it's the responsibility of the of
Muslim leaders to step forward and
combat extremism what who should be
talking to whom and in what way it's a
really tough one I think first of all
you are not going to solve a problem if
you can't actually talk about it I think
that's a contradiction in terms and we
have to be able to talk about it without
animus and without prejudice and we have
to talk about it with real humility I
mean we as Jews know what it is to have
civil war within Judaism that was the
situation in the first century as versed
Bayesian and Titus were besieging
Jerusalem if you read Josephus you will
see that the Jews inside the besieged
city were more intent on fighting one
another than the enemy outside
Christianity was there in the 16th and
17th centuries so you can actually see
that a clock ticks in the history of the
Abrahamic monotheism which says roughly
fifteen hundred years after the birth of
religion there is civil war within the
religion and we know the outcome in each
case which is that eventually wise
counsel say you have to separate
religion from power it is the only way
and it will be the only way within Islam
just as it was the conclusion reached by
Christianity and by Judaism so when we
talk about the civil war within Islam
between Sunni and Shia extremists
moderates all the rest of it then we
have to do so without the slightest
sense of transyl ism with a genuine
sense of fellow-feeling
because whether we are Jew or Christian
or other faiths we have been there
before we
know what it feels like to be part of
that and I think we have to be able to
talk about it honestly with humility and
with humanity along those lines and in
the in the spirit of fairness
traditional Judaism has had to deal with
religious extremists within our own
community and I'm wondering if I'm
wondering if there are lessons to be
drawn from how well you know III
standing when when they transfer the
worldly you know informed New York into
January 2002 out of sympathy to New York
and I stood with the chief rabbi of
Israeli Archbishop of Canterbury with
Imams and gurus and so on from the world
at Ground Zero I said we you know if
religion is part of the problem it
better be part of the solution and I
resolved then to write a book to be
published on the first anniversary of
9/11 which I did it was a book called
dignity of difference now I was chief
rabbi but my own extremists in the
community thought that this book went
several miles too far and I was accused
of heresy in fact Rowan Williams had
just become Archbishop of Canterbury and
just a week or two before he became
Archbishop of Canterbury he attended a
druid ceremony in Wales ie a pagan
ceremony summer ceremony and I should
have cut it out but I never did but
there was a headline in the national
press saying Archbishop of Canterbury
and chief rabbi accused of heresy and I
said to run I can't live in that
headline too many times in history we
really should have cut it out I said
it's got a wonderful flip side to it
that even you're if you're a heretic you
can become a chief rabbi so look we all
have extremists and I
think one of the beautiful things about
Yale in particular but about the
university in general it is it
facilitates not only inter-religious
engagement but intra religious
engagement people who wouldn't
necessarily have come together outside
the university come together here and so
while you're healing the rifts between
faiths you discover in a magical way
that you helped heal the rifts within
faiths as well yeah I appreciate your
saying that because I think it is
something that the community on this
campus the Jewish communities campus is
proud of creating the ecumenical
community of if that's the right word of
people who believe very different things
and contradictory things quite
contradictory things coming together and
actually experiencing Yale and their
Judaism together I think it was in
yesterday's paper might been in this
morning's thing was yesterday's New York
Times an article about a westerner going
off to fight in Syria or maybe it was
joining Isis I'm not sure and I was you
know as a psychologist sort of wondering
what would motivate someone to do that
and what can you know should we be
worried when such individuals come back
and rejoin society when they are they're
going to grow out of it I know that
sounds completely ridiculous but well
it's a very odd phenomenon it's not
phenomenon you can map it you know there
were these two extraordinary discoveries
in the forties the famous one made in
Qumran of what came to be known as the
Dead Sea Scrolls the discovery in 47 but
two years or slightly less than two
years earlier there was an equally
fascinating discovery not that far away
called the neg Hammadi manuscripts which
contained a series of texts that have
been known in theory because they were
condemned
by Aaron Ayers in hundred eighty but
that people knew the titles of these
books hadn't seen them before and they
can't kind of get known generically as
the Gnostic Gospels now the Dead Sea
scroll sectarians would use the nag
hammadi devotees Coptics were not they
were Christians but fascinatingly since
Judaism and Christianity of both
monotheism's what they had in common was
they were both duelists they saw the
world is divided into the children of
light and the children of darkness or
their chosen against Satan and so on and
so forth and it's very unusual to find
monotheism giving rise to this kind of
dualism and it only happens in times of
extreme turbulence where cognitive
dissonance is too deep to bear where the
way the world is is so unlike the way it
ought to have been that you can no
longer deal with this by saying all of
this came from God you've got to say the
good stuff came from God and the bad
stuff came from devil or Satan the
Antichrist or what have you you have to
divide the world that's also when you
get the politics of the apocalypse
messianic politics you know that there
always were there was exodus politics
which is the mainstream prophets which
is we can get from here to there within
normal history but then you get a kind
of despair
beginning with a prophet like Zakaria
Book of Daniel and of course New
Testament book of Revelation where the
world seems so far from where it ought
to be that we can only get from here to
there by some great cosmic encounter
some great Cataclysm and when you get
dualism and a pocket and the politics of
the apocalypse that is telling you that
cognitive dissonance within a culture is
just unbearable and this really is what
is happening today within the world
Islam and as I said we can sort of trace
that back to those two great manuscript
discoveries and I'll put those under a
microscope and see in the end what that
what they led to and I think that's
what's actually happening with is it
within Islam because monotheism is Islam
is very very much a monotheism an
austere monotheism but the world of Isis
al-qaeda Boko Haram and so on is really
a world of the children of light against
the children of darkness that's what
Boko Haram means a Western education is
heretical and forbidden so we are seeing
Islam go through as I say what Judah is
when Christianity went through at
different times this is not an unknown
it's a very very rare phenomena I think
on this campus maybe one of the things
that impresses me is that the
conversation we're just having right now
this very topic I have watched as Muslim
students here at Yale and Jewish
students here at Yelp for example eating
food that is both halal and kosher
together actually have this discussion
and I've seen groups like jamming Jews
and Muslims at Yale actually facilitate
this conversation about this kind of
thing and you know where does extremism
come from but how unique is it you know
any one group and I I'm impressed that
they can handle a conversation like that
and and do on a really on a daily basis
this is an absolutely crucial
conversation when anti-semitism began to
return to Europe I picked it up February
March 2002 I I'd never encountered it
before I mean I was
I grew most of my friends growing up
were not Jewish I never encountered a
single episode of anti-semitism until
past my fiftieth birthday
and in April 2002 I called in the
leadership of the Union
Jewish students and I said things are
going to get very tough for you on
campus and they've been tough from that
day to this and I said we're going to be
there with you I was very close to the
Jewish gym so we're not gonna leave you
alone we're gonna fight this fight with
you but I want you to do what in
psychotherapeutic terms they call
paradoxical intervention I want you to
right now lead a campaign against
Islamophobia and that's what our Jewish
students did they they were experiencing
anti-semitism but they were working with
Muslims to fight the prejudice Muslim
students faced how did that grew
something called the coexistence trust
Jews and Muslims fighting anti-semitism
and Islamophobia together it was born in
our student circles just like yours and
this is the great hope for the future
you know I want I said to when he was
still crown prince our son of Jordan
after the assassination of Yitzhak Rabin
I went over to see him in Amman and I
said to him what he's going to bring out
our two faiths together and he gave me a
very beautiful answer he said you know
shared history of tears I doubt there's
a faith in the world that has not known
suffering and persecution certainly
Christianity had its full measure of
them in its early centuries and all the
way through today I mean Christians in
the Middle East are suffering I think
what is happening to middle Christians
in the Middle East today is the crime
against humanity of our time I think
Christian communities are being
devastated in Iraq and Afghanistan the
last church was burned to the ground in
2010 you've got five million Coptic
Christians living in fear in Egypt
almost every Christian in Syria who
could leave has left you have one of the
oldest Christian communities in the
world Mosul where today there's not a
single Christian left so I think we all
know
yes and I think we have to share those
too and that can be the way of turning
the curse into a blessing the darkness
into light so you're really arguing for
you know engagement and empathy and then
you know leadership in some kind of
mutual understanding I'm wondering
wondering how that squares with the data
on Europeans particularly French is the
data I saw Jews making a Leo to Israel
they're there they're leaving and in
greater numbers than ever before now
they're they're going to Israel so one
might argue that that you know is a
positive thing in its own right but
putting that aside for a moment they're
choosing not to stay and not to engage
and not to try to build something
different in the spirit that you just
described should we be concerned about
that Peter you know just work this one
out
we are 120 years since 1895 since
Theodor Herzl a Viennese Jew sent by his
newspaper to become its Paris
correspondent stood outside the
courtyard when judgment was proclaimed
against Dreyfus and heard the crowd
shouting Maude Oh chief death to the
Jews now Theodore Herzl knew that there
had been pogroms in more than 100 rounds
in Russia in 1881 the notorious
anti-semitic May laws in 1882 he knew
anti-semitism was still there but to
experience in Paris the cultural in the
intellectual center of Europe that
convinced him Jews had no place in
Europe now to know that last summer
hundred twenty years on those same words
were heard on the streets of Paris that
sent shivers down your spine
to know that within living memory of the
Holocaust many Jews feel it is not safe
to be a Jew in mainland Europe anymore
I mean if France loses its Jews forgive
me for saying this France will have lost
its soul so this is a horrendous
horrendous situation and you know the
fact that it's anti-semitism should not
blind us to the fact that the hate that
begins with Jews never ends with Jews
and therefore it is not Jews who are on
the line it is freedom that's on the
line the freedom for which Europe fought
those intellectual and cultural battles
for 400 years this is the biggest battle
of the 21st century for the West the
soul of the West is on the line and we
have to be able to stand together Jew
Christian Muslim Hindu Sikh Buddhist
whatever and my beloved atheist like my
wonderful friend Richard Dawkins with
whom I have these wonderful 30
conversations I mean you know it's our
humanity on the line here because we are
seeing a religion in great pain
regressing to some very emotionally
unintelligent territory and 90% of the
victims of his newest violence are
Muslim and so this is the battle of our
time and we have to fight it as I say
with the wisdom of a marshal knowing not
only how to win a war but how to win a
peace and that will need greatness of
soul on the part of all of us and a
willingness to speak and hold out the
hand of friendship across boundaries and
the realization that we are enriched by
our diversity just as we are humanized
by our commonality that the whole of
humanity is this this metronome between
our commonalities now differences as I
put it if we will
different we couldn't communicate and if
we were exactly the same we'd have
nothing to say so if we can handle that
what I call the dignity of difference we
will have a future if not I think there
are tough and turbulent times there let
me return to yell to this campus we have
had struggle I would say a bit this year
previous years around trying to draw
lines between legitimate criticism of
the government of Israel or of Israel
and anti-semitism and statements that
are anti-semitic and it's a difficult
one I think people honest people often
don't come to the same conclusion about
where those lines should be drawn can be
drawn and I'm wondering if you can help
us draw those that draw those lines I
think the line is simple Jews have been
the most self-critical
critical people in history certainly my
family yes yeah
well described that way I remember doing
a public conversation in Israel with the
well-known leading securest in Israel
the novelist Amazons and he began his
opening sentence was I'm not sure that
I'm gonna agree with rabbi sacks on
everything but then on most things I
don't agree with myself
Jewish way you know we know what it is
to criticize in the State of Israel
every Israeli taxi driver does it the
whole time
say you know and the essence of free
speech is you you expose yourself to the
vulnerability of being criticized daddy
you cannot have a free society without
creating that openness that freedom of
speech and that vulnerability out of
which we grow it is when there
our attempts to silence the voice that I
have serious wise academic freedom means
being willing to listen respectfully to
views with which you do not agree now we
have an Israeli ambassador in London a
most wonderful man Daniel toke not quite
a young graduate of Oxford and Harvard a
gentle man an intellectual man who went
up to the University of Edinburgh and
was shouted down for an hour and I
thought the University of Edinburgh 14th
century University the home in the 18th
century of the Scottish enlightenment
free speech was just abandoned in one of
the great universities of Europe I don't
know how anyone could allow that to
happen it is not only a Jewish principle
and a Christian principle justice shall
helpless you it is not only yet and the
essence of Judaism that we have a whole
book of the Bible job where job is given
the freedom to criticize God and God
doesn't accuse job of being an
anti-semite so you know that's fine but
it's not only a judeo-christian
principle it is a fundamental axiom of
Roman law that justice requires aldi all
turin partum listen to the other and so
long as a university can guarantee that
and it doesn't matter how critical it is
that is not anti-semitic that is not an
assault on academic freedom but when
there's an attempt to ban to silence a
voice then we reached the stage of which
Julian bender wrote in 1927 in France
looking at what was happening to
universities in Europe and you remember
he said he wrote a book with a very
famous title latrise on declare the
treason of the intellectuals it's a very
famous title it's not a very famous book
as those four words are
the only four words that you can
understand in the entire book but it's
you know its meaning is elusive if I can
put it that way
but he does say he does say at one point
with looks at Veritas no less he does
say that academic life used to be about
the pursuit of truth and however far
short of it you fell you were at least
lifted by what you were pursuing
nowadays he said and listen to his
phrase universities have become places
for the intellectual organization of
political hatreds now if that happens to
a culture
we're in danger so no criticism of
Israel is anti-zionist or anti-semitic
but the attempt to silence the voice
that is a betrayal thank you
do we have time for one question from
the audience yes one okay so I I've been
given a card at revs I guess cards from
all from you on the way in and I'm gonna
look if you don't mind I'm gonna look
for one that's a little more personal
and I think I just found it yeah okay I
think one of our students may have
written this question and we'll finish
on this note if you are rabbi Lord Sachs
it is it easier to manage a congregation
and it would be for the average pulpit
rabbi in the UK
so so I just noticing we talked about
some of the most controversial things
that one could talk about in front of an
audience and while livestream Lobby on
Thursday and and you didn't pause before
any of the other question you think they
know what is the Lord and synagogue
we're all equal let me be very blunt
with you it's being a lord doesn't help
you at all but it it does
I think allow me to answer the question
that I am sometimes of haast which is
ever since I was admitted to the House
of Lords they say which do you prefer
the House of Lords or the house of the
Lord and I say given the choice always
choose the house of the Lord because in
the house of the Lord only the rabbi
gives a sermon in the House of Lords
everyone on that note I think we'd like
to thank you rabbi word sex thank you so
much thank you this afternoon thank you
so much
wonderful day to end
you